in today's video we will explain all 36
dragon level monsters in one punch man
we will start with bakuzan and in later
parts of the video we will explain some
monsters that are even beyond dragon
level bakuzan was considered a favorite
to win the super fight tournament and
was even titled strongest man in the
history of superfight after his
transformation into a monster bakuzan
became way more powerful than before and
was even considered a dragon level
threat after realizing saitama is the
one who defeated them during the
tournament bakuzan uses all his moves in
an attempt to get revenge on him however
none of the attacks face saktama only
moving him a short distance but due to
his extreme arrogance bakuzan cannot
comprehend the fact that saitama is
unfazed and deduces that saitama is
paralyzed by fear in order to finish the
fight he initiates the hell dispatch
chop as the final blow only for saitama
to blow off half his body killing him
number 2 psychos psychos is an esper and
the military advisor of the monster
association she is also one of the main
antagonists of the monster association
arc as the second highest ranking member
of the organization psychos has great
authority over everyone and oversees the
organization's operations and activities
she is shown to be very powerful as an
esper but not very skilled after merging
with orochi her psychic power increased
exponentially allowing her to contend
with tatsumaki and seriously harm her
although tatsumaki later revealed that
she was holding back she can send out
psychic signals to her colleagues from
great distances as well as remotely
control gyrogyro from 1500 meters
underground when her power was amplified
by her elixir cyclist was capable of
breaking free of tatsumaki's restraints
and dragging her down from a large
distance number 4. boros boros was the
leader of the dark matter thieves a
group of alien invaders responsible for
the destruction of a city similar to
saitama boros faced a self-imposed
existential crisis having become so
powerful that no battle thrilled him his
intergalactic travels in search of a
worthy opponent led him to earth where
he fought against our baldi saitama
boros was gifted of the superpowers
since birth and was only getting
stronger with time and experience he
possessed regeneration physical prowess
into latent energy that far surpassed
any members of his race boris has
displayed extreme amounts of physical
strength during his fight against
saitama he was able to knock saitama
through several pillars of his ship with
only a single punch boros could also use
the latent heat that his body produced
to fire large energy blasts from the eye
in his chest with great destructive
power these energy attacks have a huge
area of effect as the one used against
saitama was shown spreading flames
across the entire gigantic spaceship
when exploded he also combined his
energy projection with his physical
attacks resulting in shock waves and
blasts capable of destroying city-sized
areas even though boros was one of the
most powerful beings in the entire
universe he was of course eventually
killed by saitama but hey at least he
found a worthy opponent number 5.
melzergaard melzergaard was an alien and
a general of the dark matter thieves he
served as a secondary antagonist during
the alien conqueror's arc he was killed
in a fight against the s-class heroes
nettle bat puri puri prisoner atomic
samurai and bang melsergaard showed the
ability to cut the sky king down in a
single strike as well as their own
attack strong enough to blow away lane's
arm and destroy a large portion of the
land behind him with a single shockwave
from the attack with a single direct hit
he managed to temporarily knock away
bang one of the strongest s-class heroes
sending him crashing through several
pieces of concrete debris the fact that
it took four s-class heroes combined to
defeat him is testament enough to his
strength number 6. mirror mirror was a
machine god battle robot presumably
created by the organization as a dragon
level threat and a machine god mirror
was undoubtedly a very powerful being
and it was likely an upgraded version of
some of the previous machine god models
despite his function to collect data it
was incredibly biased as it failed to
analyze saitama's true power it only
based its results on saitama's
appearance and rank rather than his true
combat prowess this bias eventually
costed its own life as saitama
effortlessly destroyed it in one attack
number 7. carnage kabudo carnage kabuto
was an artificial mutant created by dr
genus and one of the strongest creations
of the house of evolution being their
strongest warrior and a dragon level
threat carnage kabuto boasted tremendous
speed and physical strength he was shown
to be strong enough to defeat genos
easily repelling his power blast with
just a forceful breath he was also said
to be highly intelligent but his
unstable personality caused dr genus to
dub him a failure carnage kabuto was
able to defeat many a-class and s-class
heroes he defeated snek in 2.52 seconds
and metal bats in around 3 minutes
however he was easily defeated by
saitama number 8 fuhrer ugly fuhrer ugly
was born in ugmon and dragon level
monster as well as an executive member
of the monster association he was
physically one of the strongest monsters
being able to crush sweet mass skull in
a single punch and to tear him apart
with apparent ease with a great deal of
effort he managed to break free of
tatsumaki's psychic hold though she was
in a severely injured and weakened state
against tank top master an s-class hero
fury ugly was able to easily counter the
hero's tank top tackle with a single
punch breaking both of his forearms in
the process and then brutally beating
him to a near-death state his incredible
strength was once again shown when he
was capable of tearing gums in half from
the inside to break free after being
swallowed by it number 9 pluton pluton
was the so-called king of the underworld
awakened due to constant pollution on
earth pluton appeared in y city and
started wreaking havoc he was about to
kill a defenseless child genus arrived
and saved the kid buying time for
saitama to appear and eliminate the
monster not much was seen of his
abilities however as a dragon level
threat it can be assumed that he was
very powerful number 10. jerry eugen
choop jerry you can shoop was an alien a
general of the dark matter thieves and
the right-hand man of boros it was an
extremely powerful esper with a very
high psychotic output and with the
ability to levitate and hurl matter
using its mind it was also able to
eliminate the friction between objects
and air defeats even above tatsumaki's
level as a result the rocks launched by
gary uganship would fly at sublight
speed without being evaporated when it
fought saitama it wasn't scared of him
showing its confidence and its skills
which while formidable were not nearly
enough to defeat saitama number 11
kuketsu kuketsu was a martial artist and
the winner of the first super fight
tournament 11 years before the events of
the series he was later challenged by a
monster king orochi to a fight in which
he was thoroughly defeated he was then
offered a chance to stay alive if he
joined the monster association which he
did gino stated that guketsu's strength
was in another dimension exceeding all
monsters he had encountered previously
and that even saitama would be impressed
by his strength he even remarked that
facing guketsu reminded him of facing
saitama himself however as later seen
guketsu was effortlessly defeated by the
bald hero number 12 hellfire flame
hellfire flame is a ninja from the ninja
village he was a member of the 37th
graduating class he and gail wind joined
the monster association sometime in the
past with the intention to rule the
world coming from the golden 37th class
of the village he's far more skilled
than most of the other ninjas possessing
s-class skills hellfire flame and gale
win display excellent teamwork skills
and cover for each other in battle
although hellfire flame is classified as
a demon level threat in his human form
his monster form takes on the
classification of dragon drastically
increasing his already immense speed
hellfire flame can change into his
monster form and revert back to his
human form freely as a powerful ninja he
has excellent control over his body
although it is stated by flashy flash
that he still lacks full control of his
power due to becoming a monster recently
number 13 kenzan rat kenzin rat appears
in h city completely destroying its east
side metal bat was sent by the hero
association to defeat it before metal
bat can engage it kenzin rat is killed
by saitama and tatsumaki who were
fighting through the cities not much is
known about its abilities however given
its enormous size and the fact that it
was rated as a dragon level threat
kenzen rat was an extremely powerful
being number 14. maru gory marugori also
called beefcake was a human who drank
the biceps branchy king's steroid
developed by fukugao which turned him
into a mutated giant marugori was
classified as a demon level threat and
would have been upgraded to a dragon if
saitama didn't stop him due to his
massive size after mutating into a giant
marugori possessed enormous physical
strength this was demonstrated when
shock waves from one of his blows caused
massive damage to an entire city he also
wielded outstanding leg strength shown
when he was able to create a large
crater by stomping on the ground the
hole he created by punching segtama was
a hundred meters wide but he was of
course defeated by saitama very shortly
after number 15. vaccine man vaccine man
was a monster born from the release of
excessive pollution and waste generated
by human beings he claimed he was
created as an incarnation of nature's
wrath and was tasked to wipe out
humanity and thus effectively vaccinate
the earth against future infections
vaccine man was a creature of great
strength and size enough so to be
classed as a threat level of dragon he
breezed through 31 heroes some of which
were a-class he was also said to be
perhaps the greatest mysterious being
that appeared till that point in time
vaccine man was capable of transforming
into a more advanced form bearing longer
claws teeth a darker coloration solid
luminescent red eyes tusks and visible
scales and spikes he could also mutate
only specific parts of his body to
preserve energy number 16 heavy smoker
heavy smoker was a large monster with
several vent pipes on his torso clawed
hands three eyes and a few strands of
hair on his head he held a tobacco pipe
in each of his hands it had six cigars
in his mouth he was able to nearly kill
tank top master an s-class hero had it
not been for flashy flash's intervention
number 17. gyorogyuro guroguro was the
meat puppet of psychos he existed as an
independent entity that allowed psychos
to manage the monster association
without revealing her identity he was
the direct military advisor to orochi
and was strong enough that the monster
king had faith in his abilities prior to
discovering tatsumaki's true power
gyorgyoro believed that he was more
powerful than her whom he had considered
one of the only four heroes capable of
defeating elder centipede guroguro was
capable of moving objects with his mind
such as the rubble that fell in garo
when the hero hunter landed in his
chambers along with stopping his
movements completely however georgiour
could not multitask very well which is
one of his major weaknesses and a flaw
that can be exploited number 18 phoenix
man phoenix man is a very strong monster
and a member of the monster association
he held a middle management position
under the association outranked only by
the executives as a demon level monster
phoenix man is a relatively powerful
being in his base form however he was
easily killed by child emperor upon
their first encounter however his true
power lies elsewhere due to his monster
form being based in a tv character that
resurrects continuously after dying
phoenix man is also capable of this and
after his resurrection he became a
dragon level threat in this state he was
strong enough to force child emperor to
use his trump card brave giant and was
able to hold the advantage for most of
the battle phoenix man's costume was the
source of his power and without it he
was as weak as a regular human number
19. pesky clown although pesky clown is
initially classified as a wolf level
threat he transforms several times
during his fight with sweet mask
eventually gaining enough strength to
make the powerful hero struggle sweet
mask estimated his highest threat level
to be dragon he is notably the only
monster thus far to force sweet mask to
use his monster form pesky clown enjoys
attention and is sadistic however once
it was clear he had no chance against
sweet mask in his transformed state he
begged for mercy indicating a cowardly
side to his personality number 20. gums
similar to pig god gums has an extremely
high digestive speed that allows him to
consume almost anything very quickly
gums stomach acid was also able to
digest fear or ugly and melt through
metal such as atomic samurai's katana
and even darkshine's extremely durable
skin causing the latter to suffer great
pain gums possess great strength he has
an incredibly strong bite force capable
of crushing heavy machinery however it
isn't strong enough to fully bite
through pig god's immense layers of fat
after exerting itself gums managed to
bite through tatsumaki's psychic barrier
which she created to shield pig god from
the destruction of the monster
association headquarters furthermore his
bite force was so powerful that even
tank top master an s-class hero with
immense physical strength was struggling
to escape its jaw number 21 grory boss
grory boss briefly appears in a futile
attempt to stop saitama from damaging
the dark matter thieves spaceship while
touting his own abilities and preparing
to strike him down he is beheaded by
saitama's punch number 22 overgrown
rover overgrown rover is an extremely
powerful being during his battle with
garo rover effortlessly with stone
multiple blows from the hero hunter and
held the advantage for the entire match
additionally both gyro aguero and orochi
were in shock and disbelief when they
heard that rover was not only defeated
but fled when given an order to attack
saitama showing that defeating such a
monster even in the eyes of the leaders
of the monster association is extremely
difficult rover is capable of firing
destructive energy bursts in rapid
succession from his mouth these energy
blasts are powerful enough to incinerate
stone level city blocks and destroy
several floors of the monster
association headquarters with ease along
with killing two demon level beings in a
single shot rover's energy blast can
also cause shock waves strong enough to
shake the surrounding surface of z city
that saitama mistook for an earthquake
in addition rover was also very durable
capable of taking hits from s-class
level combatants such as bang bomb and
garo while sustaining little to no
damage whatsoever rover also forced the
bang and bomb to use crossfang dragon
slayer fist and even though he had
already been weakened by saitama this
attack still had seemingly no effect on
him number 23. nian nian is one of the
executive members of the monster
association and is also extremely strong
this was displayed when he was able to
easily slash through puri puri
prisoner's skin which was stated to be
so tough that even razor blades couldn't
penetrate while fast and versatile nian
had trouble keeping up with drive
night's own speed and versatility as he
continuously changed forms to out
maneuver him at every opportunity
although nien was defeated by the hero
in the end drive knight admitted that he
was extremely powerful and he only won
because he collected battle data
beforehand number 24 black s black s was
able to easily overwhelm the s-class
hero atomic samurai during their battle
due to his abilities being the perfect
counter to the hero's fighting style
furthermore blackass is capable enough
to cause psychos to remark that if he
and homeless emperor team up together
they can defeat anyone even a single
black ass clone is strong enough to
easily defeat an a-class hero instead of
being killed whenever it is dealt a
fatal blow it will split into even more
copies of himself and it can even split
it well however it is still susceptible
to attacks that did not immediately cut
him to pieces such as blunt force or
acid attacks contrary to his appearance
black s possesses great strength in his
larger state he has shown capable of
restraining sweet mask the top-ranked
a-class hero and embedding genos into
the ground with a single strike number
25 apex rabbit after appearing in the
e-city thrill animal park apex rabbit
and his fellow monster herbivores run
wild until drive knight and genos arrive
apex rabbit encounters both heroes
fights them and is ultimately killed in
the battle by their combined effort
number 26 machine guard body tech and
ray body tech and rey are machine
guard's battle robots presumably created
by the organization all three of them
are classified as dragon level threats
machine god body was the first to face
the enraged genos and pretended not to
be impressed by the young cyborg's
abilities despite this it allowed his
partners to intervene and they were all
overpowered by genos body was left
damaged but still alive allowing it to
incorporate the bodies of rey and tech
into its own however the power boost
wasn't very significant as it was
quickly finished off by genos number 27
eel dragon eel dragon first appears in l
city where it obliterates the city's
business district it is promptly taken
on by blue and the two engage in combat
blue manages to dodge eel dragon's acid
shot but remarks that it's powerful it
is ultimately defeated by blue after
giving the hero a run for his money
number 28 elder centipede elder
centipede was a dragon level executive
member of the monster association and
one of the largest monsters in the
series there are only four heroes in the
hero association capable of defeating
elder centipede thotsumaki metal knight
king and blast both phoenix man and the
hero association compare elder centipede
to natural catastrophic disasters its
power was proven when it was able to
easily handle three s-class level
opponents genos bang and bomb ants would
probably be able to defeat them if not
for saitama's intervention number 29
golden s golden s is a powerful fusion
of black s cells he later merges with
over 11 trillion cells and becomes the
ultimate fusion platinum s as a fusion
of black s cells a monster that was
already classified as a dragon level
threat goldness is extremely powerful he
possesses an extreme amount of raw power
as demonstrated when he was capable of
effortlessly defeating powerful
individuals such as fuhrer ugly and
super alloy darkshine he is also
amazingly fast as demonstrated when he
was able to easily punch fear or ugly
faster than the monster could react
number 30. gale wind galewind comes from
the same ninja village as sonic and is a
very strong and skilled warrior as
galwin graduated among the golden 37th
class of the village he is shown to be
more powerful than sonic and thus could
easily qualify for the rank of s-class
in the hero association if he didn't
become a monster although galewind is
classified as a demon level threat in
his human form his monster form takes on
the classification of dragon drastically
increasing his already immense speed
gail wind can change into his monster
form and revert back to his human form
freely upon transforming gilwin's speed
increased drastically pressuring flashy
flash enough that the hero widened his
eyes in surprise forcing him to fight
seriously for the rest of their fight
flashy flash himself even commended gale
wind on his speed stating that the other
s-class heroes would have difficulty
defeating him and that he was the only
one fast enough to handle the monster
number 31 evil natural water evil
natural waters body is made entirely out
of the water and has no vulnerable
internal organs or weak points to target
thus making it almost impossible to deal
physical damage to the creature being
composed of liquid also makes it immune
to chemical attacks evil natural water
is capable of firing devastating
high-speed jets of water in an instant
the jets of water appear to be
significantly faster than bullets as
many high-ranking heroes have difficulty
dealing with them despite their
superhuman speed and reflexes however
even with multiple jet streams at once
evil natural water was unable to harm
super alloy dark shine who compared his
attacks to a nice shower evil natural
water later managed to merge with the
ocean and it became evil ocean water
growing massively in size and becoming
one of the strongest monsters ever it
was however defeated by saitama's fatal
blow disrupting the whole ocean at once
number 32 orochi orochi is the leader of
the monster association and his powers
far exceed that of average dragon level
monsters gokatsu claimed that orochi is
the strongest monster on earth psychos
called rochi the ultimate being and was
unable to gauge rochi's power calling
him a true monster orochi's main and
most terrifying ability is to change the
shape of his body at will he can shift
into many different monstrous forms when
he wants to fight with his full
capabilities orochi removes his mask and
transforms into his true form in his
released form orochi can breathe fire
from his mouth and from all the dragons
over his body and the flames are ejected
from his dragon's mouth so quickly that
they appear like beams of glowing energy
these flames are powerful enough to
completely melt the stone environment
surrounding him when he transformed
during his fight with saitama his
dragons also changed shape and became
completely enveloped in flames even
after his body was nearly destroyed by
saitama he was still able to manipulate
and transform the bits of flesh around
the headquarters number 33 garo garo is
a villain a martial arts prodigy the
self-proclaimed hero hunter and a major
adversary of both hero association and
monster association he is a former
disciple of bang but was expelled from
his dojo for going on a rampage because
of his fascination with monsters he is
commonly called the human monster
throughout the show we've seen garu
defeat many heroes in his human form
such as tank top master as well as many
a-class heroes garrow's dream of
becoming a monster became a reality when
he managed to unlock his awakened form
which completely transforms him into a
monster first form shortly after his
battle against golden s garrow completes
his first transformation he has devilish
horns on his head and his clothes are
reduced to only his pants shoes and
scarf according to genos not a single
trait of his former face remains in this
form gara was able to easily best
several s-class heroes simultaneously
while literally toying with them second
form after being pushed into a corner by
saitama garo transforms again this
transformation is intense enough to
change the direction of the wind and
convince saitama that something serious
is coming his body becomes much bulkier
and his demonic features are much more
noticeable the horns on his head are
curvy while four other horns appear on
his back and his clothes seemingly
disappear garu's teeth become larger and
his eyes give place to a black void
final form after receiving a serious
headbutt from saitama garo regenerates
and evolves one more time his appearance
becomes even more demonic and his
muscles grow to the point he is several
times larger than saitama his horns make
sharp curves now while the horns on his
back mutate into large wings unlike the
previous transformations this one
eventually crumbles and garros starts to
lose power number 34 aggregation
aggregation is only seen for a short
period of time and is quickly killed by
tatsumaki number 35 the extended family
of darkness the extended family of
darkness suddenly appear in t city and
the hero association quickly designates
them as a disaster level dragon later on
genos arrives at the scene and they
prepare to face him after exchanging
blows with the group of monsters genus
finishes the battle with an explosive
blast from his core this was the first
dragon level threat genus was able to
suppress on his own number 36 sage
centipede sage centipede is an immensely
large centipede-like monster he claims
to have emerged to destroy the
abominable fist that opposes god he is
superior in size and strength to his
underlying elder centipede who was
himself an extremely large and powerful
dragon level threat while he does bear
some resemblance to elder centipede he
is notably more monstrous to a degree
having a sharper and spiky armor that
sticks out he was able to fight against
an evolved garo and metal bat
simultaneously defeating the hero and
giving the human monster some difficulty
before ultimately losing to him it was
never officially stated that sage
centipede is a dragon level threat but
let's be honest it definitely is click
on this video where we explained all
s-class heroes in one punch man what are
you waiting for click it